well this is an extremely uh dangerous
and upsetting situation for farmers uh
right across
england who are losing their crops and
their equipment over the last 24 hours
because of the temperatures and this
prolonged dry spell we're at jm stratton
and co's
farm and you can see here the smoldering
ground this is completely torched this
ground it is still warm to the touch and
this is what we can
use
today with this tractor and this bailout
on fire you can just see
the power and of the destruction
of this tinderbox stubs this ground had
already been harvested combined here
with the wind which is blowing in
and this fire started
by
some of the equipment hitting shards of
flint combined with this material and
this straw and as that happens
it just smolders and usually the farmer
was telling me
the driver would have time to disconnect
the tractor move that away that's the
really expensive bit of equipment
and unfortunately let the other the
baler or the harvester burn there was no
time to do that he had to flee now
fortunately the driver of this equipment
yesterday here in wiltshire was unharmed
and was absolutely fine
i was due to be chatting to the owner of
this farm this is a large farm around
three and a half thousand acres here in
wiltshire he actually had to just dash
because a couple of minutes ago we saw
on the horizon we can't see it now some
smoke coming from one of his other
fields um around a mile and a half away
he called up his team over there they
confirmed it's a fire and they've gone
the situation at this now obviously this
is a very large arable farm and the
situation here is that for the first
time ever the team here have recruited
people to go around with bowsers and
water to follow their harvesters and
their tractors because this takes off so
quickly
they're needing to put these fires out
almost instantly and uh as good a job as
the fire and rescue teams do they can't
get here quick enough and so now this
this farm here has been employing their
own people to follow these pieces of
equipment with water to put out you can
just see if we just come over here you
can still see
you know
this is a very large farm some three and
a half thousand acres now fortunately
they've harvested the crop here already
and it was the stubs which should uh
caught light but i mean the temperature
is beating down
another smoldering fire still very much
a risk and what these
private fire teams are doing which have
been employed by their farm owner here
when they spot a fire they are instantly
circling around the edges creating that
protective ring to ensure that the fire
doesn't spread and that no more fires no
more crop
arguably is is damaged and that is the
real risk for them but this is actually
an incredibly sad situation in the
farmer just before he dashed to go and
tackle another fire in the last few
minutes said
i've got to go the guys up there are so
upset they're losing their crops this is
of course their livelihood and we're not
talking about the record temperatures
that we saw last month the problem here
for the farmers across the country is
just the prolonged nature of this dry
spell of uh this heat uh it's been the
driest first half of the year since 1976
and what's happening is there's simply
no moisture in the ground so it is so
tinderbox dry and you can see the
scorched earth here
this is
and that is creating an incredibly
dangerous situation for farmers up and
down the country as you can see here
fortunately the driver of this tractor
which we captured on the helicopter
yesterday was safe uh the machines lost
but fortunately he's okay